bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur france 24 pour le grand entretien en
compagnie du chef de la diplomatie
européenne entretien exclusif avec josep
borrell le haut représentant de l'union
européenne pour les affaires étrangères
et la politique de sécurité nous sommes
en duplex avec lui depuis son pays
l'espagne et sa capitale d'ailleurs
madrid bonjour monsieur bourrel
alors je rappais lourd je rappelle
qu'avec ursula von der leyen et le
premier ministre slovaque vous étiez
vendredi 8 avril à kiev vous est rendu
là bas
ce mercredi c'est charles michel le
président du conseil européen qu'il qui
fait cette visite c'est important
d'ailleurs ces visites d'européens
évidemment c'était une façon de montrer
de l'appui que nous voulons que nous
donnons à l'ukraine et dans le cas
concret de ma visite c'était aussi
l'occasion pour
rendre le formellement le
à l'ukraine au président de l'ukraine le
formulaire qu'il doit remplir pour
commencer les processus d'adhésion oui
je pense que c'était valeur symbolique
important les troupes russes ont entamé
la bataille du dombass en multipliant
les bombardements vous vous avez dit
l'issue ce jour à l'issue du conflit en
ukraine se jouera sur le champ de
bataille et son chéri dalal de
l'autriche est allé le voir à moscou il
a rentré les mains vides parce que
poutine veut il a dit que la banque
devait continuer la guerre alors si il
n'y a pas la possibilité de négocier si
poutine ne vais pas négocier mais si la
guerre continue évidemment le sens de la
guerre va se jouer dans les champs de
bataille
ça m'étonne que ça étonne alors il ya ça
étonne c'est clair comme l'eau l'union
européenne a également proposé de porter
à 1,5 milliard le total de son aide
depuis le début de l'invasion aide pour
acheter des armes les ukrainiens vont
recevoir des armes lourdes mais
principalement des vieux équipements de
fabrication soviétique qu'ils ont
l'habitude de manier washington tente
d'ailleurs de convaincre les pays
européens ne leur donnait ses
équipements là on échange de matériel
américain récents est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que tout est fait pour les
aider du côté des armes
tout qu'est ce que ça veut dire tous ont
fait beaucoup
de 5 milliards socialement la partie qui
est financée avec le budget européen
mais il faut additionner tous les états
membres fonctionnel de son côté sur
l'addition tous c'est beaucoup plus m
il a amené beaucoup plus il ya des pays
qui ont des pensées des gens un tiers de
son budget dépenses défense pour le
délivrer
l'aide européenne va au delà de ces
milliards et demi croyez moi parce que
là beaucoup d'états l'allemagne vient
d'annoncer elle toute seule un milliard
donc en fait pas la guerre avec des
billets de banque il faut transformer
des ressources financières en ressources
matérielles
il faut que ces ressources matérielles
soit là où on peut les utiliser et que
ceux qui vont les utiliser ce soit
capable de les faire mais c'est ça qu'on
est en train de faire pour donner des
points de vue logistique ce que les
états membres font pour éviter la
duplication
coordonnées
les apports de chaque étape de manière à
donner aux clients s'étant qu'ils ont
besoin d'aller refaire arrivée est allé
matériel que
sont pas utilisables parce que beaucoup
plus informés incomplet pas on peut pas
facilement est tout de suite en
entraîner les secondes à utiliser les
armes avec lesquelles n'ont jamais
travaillé c'est pour ça que l'essai de
fournir des cendres qui viennent de
délestage armes de l'époque soviétique
ce pour tout simple l'union européenne a
condamné les frappes de missiles aveugle
et illégaux contre des civils menés par
la russie en ukraine et dénoncé des
crimes de guerre des crimes qui seront
jamais punis selon vous josette borel
pour moi jamais voyez ce que s'est passé
dans la sienne du bourg-l'abbé les
coupables de crimes de guerre dans
l'ancienne yougoslavie
finalement 13 ans ont été jugés ils ont
été condamnés ils sont heureux de sa
peine jamais je ne sais pas évidemment
c'est difficile mais en ce moment le
problème c'est
beaucoup fois encore la guerre elle même
le clan se bat pour son existence c'est
une garantie essentielle pour les
plaines unir les crimes est l'un des
guerres oui bien sûr il faudra les faire
mais pour l'instant la surface
importante c'est être capable de la
gestion d'un passeur sera juste elle un
patient russe l'embargo sur le gaz le
gaz dont l'allemagne est très dépendante
et est difficile à négocier voire
impossibles à obtenir des vingt-sept le
front européen est ce qu'il n'est pas en
train de se fissurer selon vous si on
peut plus progresser dans le dans
l'arsenal de sanctions efficaces pour
stopper un conflit pas les flottes
européennes n'a jamais été aussi unis
aient jamais vu autant d'unités le nom
européenne vous savez ces 27 pays et
chacun voit les choses d'une façon
différente mais cette fois ci le d'été a
été très ferme eux mêmes des pays qui
ont des rapports amical avait au 3 de la
rue si on fait partie de la décision de
pourvoir des armes les sanctions n'ont
jamais vu autant d'unités évidemment il
ya les problèmes des gars c'est le
pétrole qui est pour l'instant
y a pas un accord pour faire 1
interdiction complète mais chaque état
fait son côté ce qui peut conduire
l'indépendance tout le monde est en
train de nourrir le sas ya des gaz et du
pétrole russes
pour le pétrole mondial que faudrait y
aller il faudrait y aller vite à une
interdiction parce que c'est beaucoup
plus simple de se situer les pétroles
que les gas mais aussi pour les gars il
faut penser à institutions massive les
deux russes pour d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement
particulier les états unis de l'afrique
moyen-orient vous étiez au forum
diplomatique de doha vous recherchez à
la fois un accord diplomatique de ces
pays de ces pays du golfe et puis aussi
l'idée d'une d'une nouvelle source
d'approvisionnement est ce que c'est en
train de marcher ça et vous savez on
peut pas du jour au lendemain d'un d'une
façon magique
chercher car en portant des casques de
notre consommation globale qui
aujourd'hui il vient de la russie mais
il faut mettre à contribution les
alternatives et sans doute
les pétards est une alternative le
catamar montée c'est c'est en bois des
garçons europe
mais il faut qu'il mette en exploitation
de nouveaux champs mais il faut le faire
il faut chercher partout des
alternatives la qatar c'est une mais les
états une autre en ce moment en ce
moment l'europe reçoit déjà plus des gas
naturel liquéfié que des gaspards d'ageo
doute de savoir monter mais j'insiste on
peut pas faire ça fait d'un mur au
lendemain il faut rechercher des anciens
native c'est l'alternative je ne peuvent
être le plus coûteuse faut savoir quel
est le coût que le prêt à payer mais
elle existe mais il faut le développer
c'est pas possible de l'ami au lendemain
c'est compréhensible ce que j'ai dit
vous comprenez les gens me comprennent
pas ce que ne peut pas faire des
miracles veut pas faire de miracle on
peut pas faire de miracles mais on s'est
rendu compte aussi que ce qu'on pensait
être nos partenaires naturels les
africains peut-être l'amérique du sud
aussi
finalement se sont abstenus dans un
certain nombre de votes sur justement
pour contre la russie et ça ça a été un
choc pour nous là aussi je crois que
vous vous prévoyez un prochain voyage en
amérique du sud parce que il faut il
faut ramener finalement à la fois les
africains et d'amérique du sud dans
notre camp des démocraties
et lacéré lazer aussi il faut faire un
travail diplomatique beaucoup plus
intense il faut être beaucoup plus
présent il faut plus expliqué plus la
nature russe qui raconte au monde que
les problèmes de la crise alimentaire la
crise énergétique la conséquence de nos
socios qu'en réalité la conséquence de
la guerre en hausse en surnombre rien à
voir si les ruines bloc
l'exportation du blé
craignant parce que c'est ça qu'ils sont
en train de faire évidemment il y aura
moins de blaine afrique à qui la faute
alone on a eu jeu et qui bloque le sport
mais ça il faut l'expliquer il faut
savoir aussi qu'il ya dans le monde
aussi une certain sentiment
anti-occidental ans qui vient de la
mémoire
anticolonialiste surtout en afrique et
il ya des pays qui voient là dernier
grain comme l'événement lointain qui
s'éteint à faire deux européens mais qui
n'a pas l'importance politique nous
avons des cas donc il faut contrer la
propagande et la désinformation russe et
il faut aller voir tout le monde parce
que c'est passé simple nous on craque
pour ce que l'on défend d'être
international tout le monde doit être
derrière nous et on a vu que c'est pas
comme ça qu'il ya des pays qui se sont
dérobés qui n'ont pas été présents à
l'air de condamner la russie les pays
qui sont très proches de nous par
exemple le maroc ou le sénégal al marri
latine
la pouille a été beaucoup plus forts
mais dernièrement cette réunion par les
montées à la bono zaïdis et oui il ya eu
un vote qui n'a qui n'a pas été un vote
ferme contre la russie au niveau de la
sueur gêné de vote a été massif 140 un
vote contre la russie mais il faut
soigner les opinions publiques parce
qu'elle se tenait un public son pressoir
des narrative qu'il faut contrer du
contraire on peut faire de la bataille
des idées c'est votre c'est le sens de
votre visite au chili et à panama
prochain
oui au panama y aura tous les ministres
des affaires étrangères de l'amérique
centrale le chili un nouveau président
qui vient de gagner les élections par ce
genre de gauche est en général amérique
latine tourne-à-gauche
barque qu'est ce que c'est parce en
colombie le chili a été très ferme et à
ma condamnation de la russie il faut que
les ministres se mobilisent fait les
commissaires se mobilisent où je vous
dis à une bataille de narrative et on va
avoir bientôt une diplomatie de la
diplomatie de la nourriture on avait de
la diplomatie des masques on avait de la
diplomatie de la bd de la kz1 bientôt
les rues souvent utilisé une diplomatie
de la ne retire des gens ont fourni du
blé
ac qui sont nos amis ça va arriver il
faut empêcher cette narrative toxiques
qui dit le problème alimentaire
énergétique du monde c'est la
conséquence des sanctions occidentales
contre la russie non c'est pas vrai
c'est la conséquence de l'agression de
la russie et l'ukraine
merci josep borrell en tout cas d'avoir
partagé justement votre analyse
aujourd'hui sur france 24 merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]